So now that we've covered
reading content on piazza,
what about posting content?
To post a new thread,
click New Post in the top left.
At the top,
you'll select your Post Type.
>> When you're posting a new topic,
it's really helpful to select
the right kind of post.
Are you asking a question that will have
one right answer, like a due date or
a clarification on directions?
The you probably want to use a Question.
Are you just sharing something,
or asking for
something with multiple good answers,
like help solving a problem?
That's usually better suited for a Note.
Or, if you want to ask a poll question,
you could always just choose Poll.
>> Piazza lets you communicate
privately, as well.
You can share your post
with the whole class,
with only a group you're a member of,
or only with instructors.
Next, select the folder
your posts will go into.
A single post can go into
more than one folder.
Then enter your title and post text.
Depending on your class, you might be
able to choose to remain anonymous.
All though not all
classes have this option.
Then, click Post My Question and
your post will appear.
Or, you can save it as
a draft to return to later.
You'll see a list of your drafts
at the top of the topic lists
whenever you start to create a new post.
But, for now,
I'll go ahead and post this.
After posting,
you can edit the post by clicking
the edit button in the bottom left.
You can also access other options with
the actions menu in the top right.
Only inspectors can delete post.
But you can change the visibility
if you post by mistake.